the Joe Rogan experience loose Monaco B
will make space to throw punches which
could get them in trouble mm-hmm against
somebody like him because he has power
in his left hand is [ __ ] NASA and
ridiculous like if you pull up you you
see the fight with him when he not when
he dropped when he wobbled or dropped
Nick Diaz yeah [ __ ] don't get drop the
[ __ ] know how crazy is Nick Diaz Nick
Diaz forced him into a dogfight
that's the scores did we do a dogfight
yes yeah and that was one of the most
freakish weirdest knockouts that was
amazing but things that was when UFC had
first taken over Strikeforce and I was
sitting there case sighs and I'm
thinking to myself this is hands-down
the greatest MMA one-round fight I've
ever seen in my life it was a man ver
I'm not amazing he just wore him out
yeah but he just put that [ __ ] Nick
Diaz pace on them and wore him out but
when he clipped him and rocked him and
dropped him I was like oh my god Paul
Taylor's gonna stop Nick Diaz Nick
fought him that way yeah I mean Nick
didn't try to take him down Nick didn't
rise submit him he just went after him
just like come on let's do this but
let's not forget the history of Nick
Diaz man well it all started with Robbie
Lawler the history of Nick Diaz started
with Robbie Lawler like come on
[ __ ] I got ya and that's what
that's what elevated him to that next
level
I called that right he walked into the
Octagon he started yelling stalked him
[ __ ]
stop and Rob you Lara's like what is
happening here what is this like Robbie
Lawler was this dark destroyer I'm
scared to him he was a spooky dude he
was flatlining people and Nick Diaz not
only was he not scared of him he was
talking mad [ __ ] to him he was fighting
he's like what [ __ ] will be doing [ __ ]
you doing [ __ ] and people don't
understand this is so funny I have
talked I was talking to big Johnnie
other day on our show I was saying like
hey man the guys that I didn't got so
damn tired when guys talk to me remember
when Nick Diaz did that to Frank
Shamrock
yeah I'm sure mark was like I can't
believe this has happened this usually
Frank that does it I trained with Frank
for years and like where I'm in his
guard he's like come on Josh get up like
throw punches do something I'm a [ __ ]
sub you I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do
that and you're just like shut up man
showers want to punch you harder and it
makes you more tired and the fact that
Nick was doing it and how
car-dealing him yes Frank's thing was
always be in the best shape so you could
put like when he beat Tito
yeah let's put that pace on I'm and Tito
couldn't keep up and then he finished
him yeah Frank was not the same guy when
he fought [ __ ] that time but let's be
real like at the time like it was just
it was awesome to see somebody like like
Nick do that because Nick though if you
can recall at the end of the fight picks
Frankie up it's like you're your legends
do not sit down there like that you're a
[ __ ] legend and that's what people
talk to me all the time about my fight
with Nate and I say look man nothing but
respect for both those guys those guys
are [ __ ] animals not only are the
animals but what I love is I love people
we were talking about Big John being a
good God before we came on the show yeah
Big John McCarthy and I said absolutely
and when I think of guys that are good
guys I think of guys that stick by their
friends no matter what
you got to remember that brawl that
happened on CBS right we were talking
about that as well that brought with
mayhem Miller Jake Shields Nick Diaz but
guess what that whole scrap pack that
they die for each other yeah and you
can't knock friendship like that and I
and I look at those guys and they're
really good people from Gilbert Melendez
his wife Kerry Nick and Nate and Jake
Jake's like still one of my good good
buddies Gillis is well but even though I
don't talk to me anymore really like but
it's still I have nothing but respect
yes
those guys themselves they did it on
their own and they're [ __ ] amazing I
will buy their pay-per-view every single
time they fight no matter what agreed
and you know Nick Dee has changed the
game in terms of his elite cardio he did
something that it was a new thing and
that new thing was he's not gonna hit
you with a hundred percent power he's
gonna hate with 50 percent but he's
gonna hit you twice as much and you're
never gonna get to breathe and he's
gonna stay on top of you and he's gonna
talk to you the whole time so he's gonna
[ __ ] with you psychologically he's gonna
disrupt your breathing but constantly
hitting you huh and then once he
realizes you're hurt then he's digging
to the body then he's putting it on you
and on top of that black belt you Jitsu
skills really good wrestling takedown
defense [ __ ] chin made of iron and an
unstoppable will like his will to beat
you was just unstoppable one when Nick
was at the top and Strikeforce
to this day I think he's one of the best
fighters has ever done it yeah
to this day no I agree I think a lot of
that unstoppable will though comes from
him doing triathlons that's like hey I
cannot stop otherwise I lose my time and
I'm only got five more miles or eight
more miles
until I get to the bike or I get to the
run or until I'm at until I get to the
I'm done with the swim those are things
in your mind as an athlete you're always
thinking like I'm almost there yeah okay
I'm only gonna run till the to the the
two-minute mark a I'm only gonna run to
the 5-minute you set goals for yourself
as you go should I smash the goal
okay one more go ahead those are the
things that top athletes do and I feel
like that's what he's done with his
career he used triathlons to help get
him there yeah he was always good always
nasty like good jujitsu great phenomenal
guillotines his game has always been
really good when he upped his game and
that bought in boxing and the pace like
you're saying just the touch touch touch
now Bam Bam touch touch touch bet that's
next-level boxing that we hadn't seen in
MMA at the time yeah and sparring with
Andre Ward on a regular basis yes I mean
he did look he he he did really change
things he really changed things
particularly with that [ __ ] cardio of
his he has some spooky cardio
[Applause]